this year's game awards was packed full
of hot new trailers for the biggest
upcoming games
we've rounded up the best ones from the
event if you want to catch the latest
gaming trailers as soon as they drop
make sure to like this video and
subscribe to gamespot enjoy
uh
[Music]
huh
[Music]
[Music]
good
[Music]
so
[Music]
is
[Music]
good
[Music]
cup
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
i remember when everything changed
the floods the storms
the fires people dying
in the streets
the corporations gave us solutions
[Music]
a better world
[Music]
and we welcome them into our lives
but the laws of nature aren't meant to
be broken
we need to know what they're hiding
oh
[Music]
yes
did you find the answers you were
looking for
agent dark not yet
this is just the beginning
[Music]
what's up
[Music]
welcome recruit get yourself acquainted
with the layout of the top at airship
enough slacking go to your tasks
you may need to take a ladder to get to
certain areas or maybe just take a nice
shortcut
quit grouping up choose a room to start
in after a meeting
someone keeps trying to sabotage us stop
their plan
keep your eyes peeled we definitely have
an impostor here
[Music]
it's time to go
hmm
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
lights out old friend
[Music]
so
i face tyrants and would-be gods
seen friends lose life and limb
but there's always someone bent on
breaking
the world
[Music]
it's time for a new hero
no magic hand
no ancient prophecy
the kind of person they'll never see
coming
we've got your back i've got your back
demons dragons dark spawn
even the dread wolf
this is your story
me
[Music]
[Music]
oh
hey man get up
[Applause]
[Music]
seeing this something ain't right
foreign
[Music]
this is black iron to transport ship
carry on
you are cleared for landing
[Music]
so
civilians are required to stay in their
own homes
take my life just now today
[Music]
um
there's too many stick together we got a
job to do
remember no worm ridden son of a [ __ ]
is gonna stop us
[Applause]
what the hell cover me
man what is that
take it out
oh man this was my favorite hoodie a
little club soda will take that right
out
watch out
this is the story of a magical king
one of wizards and worries
it's an epic dame sent upon the high
seas
an odyssey through time and space
it's also a bit of a winter wonderland
bobsled sort of thing you know
oh wait did i mention the big explosion
all the writing look at these dolls
almost forgot they used to be humans
do you want to know what this story is
really about
huh this is the story
of cody
why'd you look like a flop of play wanna
change back
then you need to fix your relationship
this is a story of attraction
can you feel it i feel
stuck
it was a spell i am telling you if it is
a spell
how do we break it okay i got this give
me some space i need to think
[Music]
how comes you get all the cool gadgets
cause i'm cooler than you cody
just behind you yeah what are you doing
you're not feeling it no okay you're
entitled to your own opinion
[Music]
my end is waiting at the beginning
i will go there now
the crash every time what is this
cycle i'm trapped inside
another end another beginning
[Music]
[Music]
we know now that in the early years of
the 20th century
this world was being watched
right eagle houston your gopher landing
over
[Music]
unknown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you